[Music]
cannot be the policy of a great nation
to up and reward those who unlawfully
enter its country with legal status
Social Security welfare food stamps work
permits and so forth
how can this be a sound policy meanwhile
those who engage in the process lawfully
and patiently and wait their turn are
discriminated against it seems at every
turn all right that was more of the
Attorney General Jeff session speaking
today in California about our nation's
immigration policy joining us now the
author of stranger the challenge of a
Latino immigrant in the Trump error
Univision anchor Jorge Ramos Jorge
welcome back good to see you sir great
to be here thank you all right let's
just for the first second put aside daca
let's put aside chain migration let's
put aside the visa lottery I want to
talk specifically about criminal aliens
in the United States those that came
here illegally those that committed
crimes those that our immigration
officers ice and others are trying to
deport do you support that let me just
say that the vast majority of immigrants
and the vast majority of undocumented
immigrants in this confession are not
criminals as a matter of fact all the
reports that I've seen and all the
reports that you've read clearly
conclude to be behind bars those are the
faction I went down to the border I'll
give you facts because I was on
horseback all-terrain vehicle I was in
helicopters I was in boats and I sat
through a security briefing in Texas
with Rick Perry six hundred and forty
two thousand crimes committed by illegal
immigrants against Texans alone here's
my question putting all those issues
aside those that commit crimes in
America including some violent crimes
even murder those criminal aliens do you
support yet having them removed from
this country absolutely I have no I have
no problem with that I'm not here to
defend real criminals but we cannot
criminalize the whole immigrant
population simply because of what a few
have died if something right
I do that know that all the white
population is responsible for what's
been prob did in in Las Vegas that will
be completely unfair it's exactly the
same thing here Shawn let me give you
one statistic illegal aliens accounted
for 13% of all non immigration related
federal sentences in 2016 now that is a
significantly higher percentage than the
3.5% estimated population of Alito you
just got done saying all immigrants
don't commit crimes I will agree with
you but that is a much higher percentage
than the rest of the population and no
country I have different numbers the
according to the migration policy
institute less than 3% of undocumented
immigrants come in felonies and that in
this case on main instances has to do
with fake IDs this percentage is much
lower than the rest of the US population
so basically my concern Shawn is that
you are impressive and from and many of
these followers are criminalizing an
immigrant population who is not
responsible for the economic problems
that we have in this country but you
know some of the worry you never went
are you saying that the people that i
sat with those were security people law
enforcement border agents i sat in a
meeting and I'll put it up on the screen
the criminal aliens have been
responsible about six hundred forty two
thousand offenses criminal offenses six
hundred and forty two thousand crimes
thanks to Texas in Texas alone yes over
two hundred thousand it's individuals
their criminal history reflected there
was data they were committed over six
hundred forty two thousand crimes that's
the cost are you literally saying to me
that they're lying because they're not
and the problem is what are you sound
like you have to you sound like you
don't care about the Americans that are
ridiculous I'd crime that that of course
I do don't respect our law of course I I
do care I live in this country my
children living in this country and you
have to put those numbers in perspective
because user project
perspective to your audience shown that
most immigrants in most undocumented
immigrants are criminals and you know
they don't want to get in trouble with
why they don't want to get in trouble
with a lot they don't want to get in
trouble with want to prosper and help
the rest of America I would argue your
point but you're wrong at another point
you're right
the vast majority and having been to the
border 13 times everywhere from the Rio
Grande to San Diego and having been in
the drug warehouses I would argue yeah
they want to leave the poverty that many
of them faced in Mexico and have more
opportunity here in America I'm saying
doing it legally but there are six
you're not answering my question six
hundred and forty two thousand crimes
committed against Texans alone in a
seven year period that's not your family
Jorge where's your sympathy for those
victims of crime and why shouldn't we
take those that are committing crimes
and get rid of them tomorrow III again I
yeah we would you completely I'm not
here to defend real criminals I'm not
here to defend real criminals but then
if you just put those numbers in context
and you don't tell the people you don't
tell your audience the truth the fact
that immigrants are less likely to be
criminals
that's not factually active United State
address Kate Steinle family because
there are a lot of families that have
sadly been victimized by those people
here illegally
that commit more crimes what do you say
to her family I I cannot even imagine
anybody's way to feel what what they are
going through I I cannot I cannot even
think about that that there is no there
is no excuse for that and no excuse
exactly but but again if you say that
all undocumented immigrants are
responsible for these crimes it is it is
obvious and it is you nobody saying that
you're inferring that you're not
inferring very directly and you're
presenting it exactly as president from
there and that is that is not I am
saying to the mayor of Oakland stop
aiding
and abetting criminals that committed
more crimes those that are here
illegally and committed crimes on top of
that and I think you should want that
Mayor to do the same
stop if you're talking about sanctuary
cities I see sanctuary cities are saying
no in California in 1950 so you don't
believe water
I do believe no but somebody but
somebody has to help immigrants one and
second this policy established by
President Trump and backers it back his
administration is already helping a lot
of bad hombres president Trump and
supported daca president your president
not forget let's not forget that the
person who killed akka he's called me
let me ask you a question will you go
down with me into a town hall in Texas
and we'll invite the 642 thousand
families those that would like to come
that war victims of crime and listen to
their stories let me let me take you you
come yes I'll do a show with you and
then we'll decide who's gonna be
attending that show but I think our news
at 10:00 this conversation is
interesting and I appreciate that you
give me the opportunity just to have it
I got a rod we got we have to continue I
understand all right Thank You Shawn